اهلا بكم يتصاعدوا التوتر في غزه وتتصاعد
التهديدات بتوسيع الحرب لتشمل كافه
الجبهات
فقد اطلق اليوم اكثر من 300 صاروخ على
اسرائيل بعضها استهدفت الابيب وعطل حركه
الملاحه في مطار بن غوريون فيما اعلنت
الغرفه المشتركه للفصائل الفلسطينيه في
غزه مسؤوليتها عن اطلاق هذه الصواريخ رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو تواصل مع
رؤساء البلديات في المنطقه الجنوبيه
وابلاغهم بامكانيه توسع العمليه العسكريه
القائمه في قطاع غزه وتوجيه ضربات عنيفه
هناك
[موسيقى]
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي قالت ان حركه حماس
لم تدخل المعركه بعد وان حركه الجهاد هي
المسؤوله عن اطلاق الصواريخ
الاعلام الاسرائيلي اعلن ان اكثر من 300
صاروخ تم اطلاقها من غزه نحو اسرائيل ووصل
عدد منها الى تل ابيب حيث تم تفعيل صفارات
الانذار
وقد اظهرت مقاطع مصوره هروب السكان الى
المنهج كما ادى الهجوم الى تعطل حركه
الملاحه الجويه في مطار بن غوريون وحدوث
اضطرابات في هبوط واقلاع الطائرات
من حدود قطاع غزه تنضم اليه الان لانك
الغاصم مراسله العربيه لنا اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد المشهد الميداني لانا وهل هذه هي
حدود هذه المواجهه الحاليه ام لا الساعات
المقبله ستكون حبله بالمفاجاه
اهلا بك فعليا نعم يعني توترات كبيره منذ
صباح اليوم في قطاع غزه وايضا في
المستوطنات على غلاف غزه كما تفضلت هناك
اطلاق اكثر من 300 قذيفه صاروخيه وصواريخ
من قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه التي قامت
باطلاقها من مناطق مختلفه من قطاع غزه نحو
ايضا مناطق عديده منها غلاف مستوطنات غلاف
غزه عبر صواريخ قصيره المدى وايضا هناك
صواريخ اكثر من 100 صاروخ كانوا ايضا
عباره عن صواريخ طويله المدى ومتوسطه
المدى التي ايضا اجتازت مستوطنات الغلاف
واستطاعت الوصول ايضا الى مدينه يافا
ومدينه تل ابيب وسط اسرائيل ومناطق اخرى
يعني كان هناك قبل قليل ايضا
السلاح الجو الاسرائيلي قام ايضا يعني
باطلاق قذائف عفوا بقصف من قبل الطائرات
لمنطقتين في قطاع غزه انهم تابعين
للفصائل الفلسطينيه ومنذ بدايه فعليا هذا
العدوان هناك اكثر من اربعين منطقه تابعه
للا موقع تابعين للفصائل الفلسطينيه قامت
السلاح الجو بقصفهم لنا هل دخلت حركه حماس
المعركه او هذه المواجهه ام لا الامور
مقتصره على حركه الجهات فقط
يعني قبل قليل كان هناك بيان خرجت به غرفه
العمليات المشتركه لما يعرف بفصائل
المقاومه وهذه الغرفه في طبيعه الحال تكون
تضم جميع الفصائل المقاومه حسب ما يتم
تسميتها وبذلك يعني تكون حركه حماس ايضا
حاضره في هذه الغرفه وبذلك هناك اعداد
كبيره ايضا من من كبار المسؤولين يقولون
بان حركه حماس ايضا كانت متواجده بهذه
الغرفه وشاركت باطلاق هذه
القذائف من قطاع غزه نحو المستوطنات ونحو
مناطق مختلفه في اسرائيل ولكن الان الحديث
عن ايضا وجود وساطه مصريه تحاول الحديث مع
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه لوقف هذا
التصعيد ووقف هذه الصواريخ التي تنطلق منه
قطاع غزه ولكن ربما سوف نشهد تصعيد وهذا
ما تقوم به
فعليا الحديث عنه الجانب الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو ايضا حذر وقال ربما سوف
يتم تصعيد فعليا هذا العدوان وسوف يكون
هناك تدخل من قبل
جهات يعني جوانب مختلفه ليس فقط في قطاع
غزه انت بالنسبه الى الجبهه الداخليه او
ما يسمى بالجبهه الداخليه الاسرائيليه هل
سيتمكن نتنياهو من ترميم جبهته الداخليه
عبر خيار الحرب هذا والهروب الى الامام ام
لا ما يجري سيزيد الطين بله في الداخل
الاسرائيلي
ربما يعني عدد كبير من كبار المسؤولين
ايضا يقولون بان ربما نتنياهو يستغل هذا
الموقف ويستغل يعني اغتيال القاده في قطاع
غزه ليثبت للداخل الاسرائيلي باننا
نتنياهو قادر على الرد على الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في في قطاع غزه وايضا بعض هذه
الفصائل تقوم بتوجيه بعض العمليات في
الضفه الغربيه وبذلك ربما هذه ايضا
يعني العمليه التي تحدث حاليا في قطاع غزه
تحت يعني تخدم نتنياهو في الداخل
الاسرائيلي وهناك ايضا اقوال من قبل وهو
وزير الامن القومي الذي يتباهى بهذه القصف
ويتباهى باغتيال القاده الذين ينتمون
للفصائل الفلسطينيه يعني الحديث عن يعني
رد فعل كبير من قبل اسرائيل وربما هذا سوف
يخدم بنيامين نتنياهو فعليا في الجبهه
بهذا القدر من حدود غزه لانك الغاص مراسله
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المتابعه
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي في خاي
ادراري اعلن ان الجيش الاسرائيلي استهدف
معدات اطلاق الصواريخ التابعه لحركه
الجهاد في قطاع غزه واكد ان الجيش وسع
غاراتي وكثفها في عده مناطق متفرقه
بالقطاع وتركزت اهداف القصف الاسرائيلي
على مطلقيه الصواريخ في قطاع غزه بحسب
بيان الجيش فيما اوضحت مصادر الفلسطينيه
ان سلسله من الغارات الاسرائيليه استهدفت
اراضي زراعيه في بلده القراره في مدينه
خان يونس
وافادت المصادر بمقتل شخص واصابه اثنين من
المزارعين اثراء قصف في منطقه عبسان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات